So let's illustrate once more what happens if we take this HTML string
and put this through our binary search simplification process.
Here is our HTML string, and we first check the first half and see if it fails.
Yes, this also fails.
But now we are splitting this string into two substrings, namely this one.
It passes.
Now the second one, and it passes as well.
In this case the binary search algorithm is stuck,
because the first half doesn't result in a simplification,
second half doesn't result in a simplification either.
So, we stop here and simply return the entire string,
which is what binary search does.
As humans, of course, we have a good idea on what to do next.
What we would do is,well, we could for instance go and cut away smaller parts.
For instance, in here, we already would see the structure and fo.
We could, for instance, go and remove the "fo" because it's different from the HTML tag.
A computer may not recognize these structures,
but what a computer can do still is to try to remove smaller chunks.
That is, rather than trying to remove entire halves,
we would try to remove, say, quarters or eighths of the input
until we're down to removing single characters.
What we do in this situation is we increase the granularity,
that is, we take away smaller parts more frequently
until we end up removing single characters
such that we really, really get an input where every single character
or every single part is relevant for reproducing the failure.
This precise strategy is called delta debugging and here's how it works.